rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de l'étranger
d'Albert Camus
l'étranger et le premier roman d'Albert
Camus publié en 1942 c'est un roman très
court mais aussi très dense reconnue
tant pour ses qualités littéraires que
pour sa profondeur philosophique
et ce qui fait la particularité de
l'étranger sur le plan littéraire c'est
la simplicité du style
des phrases courtes des descriptions
minimalistes on n'est pas chez Proust
et pourtant derrière cette apparente
simplicité d'écriture on va trouver dans
l'étranger un véritable itinéraire
philosophique
l'itinéraire de Meursault un homme dont
on ne sait presque rien si ce n'est
qu'il vit en Algérie on est encore avant
l'indépendance et qu'il vient de perdre
sa mère
c'est même sur cette annonce que s'ouvre
le roman avec cette citation bien connue
aujourd'hui maman est morte ou peut-être
hier je ne sais pas
l'étranger c'est l'histoire d'un homme
qui apprend que sa mère vient de mourir
qui n'en n'est pas affecté ou plutôt qui
semble ne pas en être affecté et qui
portait par le hasard des circonstances
va commettre un meurtre
Meursault va être jugé et condamné à
mort et paradoxalement c'est cette
condamnation à mort qui va lui permettre
de trouver un sens à l'existence
comment et bien c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de comprendre dans cet épisode
alors pour ceux qui suivent cette chaîne
vous savez que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de vous parler d'Albert Camus et de sa
philosophie de l'absurde une philosophie
de l'absurde qui nous a livré au travers
de trois grandes œuvres l'étranger
Caligula et le mythe de Sisyphe
et donc dans mon précédent épisode sur
Camus j'ai pris le parti de vous parler
de ces trois œuvres à la fois justement
du fait de leur unité philosophique
mais l'inconvénient de cette approche
c'est qu'elle ne permet pas de rentrer
dans le détail
or chacune de ces trois œuvres
mériterait un épisode à part entière
donc ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on se concentre
uniquement sur l'étranger et vous allez
voir à quel point cette œuvre nous offre
matière à réflexion
et pour ce faire on va commencer par
dresser le portrait du personnage
principal Meursault pour ensuite
progressivement nous demander ce qu'il
incarne ce qui l'incarne
philosophiquement parlant
Meursault est un homme entouré de
mystère
on ne connaît pas son prénom on ne
connaît pas son âge ni son passé
on sait juste qu'il travaille comme
employé de bureau à Alger et qu'il
fréquente une femme Marie
qui semble amoureuse de lui mais sans
que ce soit tout à fait réciproque
par exemple quand Marie lui demande s'il
aime il lui répond il me semble que non
quant à lui demande s'il veut l'épouser
il lui répond ça m'est égal
la grande place
alors on pourrait se dire que c'est
juste un goujat
pas besoin de recourir à une analyse
philosophique
et bien c'est pas aussi simple
parce que on pourrait se dire que c'est
juste un goujat si Marie était la seule
personne avec qui il se comportait comme
ça
or Meursault est comme ça avec tout le
monde
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut entendre par
être comme ça il faut entendre d'une
intransigeante sincérité
Meursault est incapable de ne pas être
sincère
c'est ça qu'il caractérise
quand Meursault dit à Marie qu'il ne
l'aime pas il ne cherche pas à la rendre
triste
autrement dit ce n'est pas par sadisme
qui lui dit ça
c'est par souci de vérité
et d'ailleurs il aime bien Marie il aime
son rire il aime sa peau il aime sa
présence
mais il ne l'aime pas au sens où on
entend habituellement le verbe aimer
l'usage veut que quand on est en couple
on se dit je t'aime
et que si l'un des deux dit à l'autre je
t'aime l'autre doit dire la même chose
en retour
et bien pas Meursault
Meursault ne dit pas ce que l'autre veut
entendre
il lui dit ce qu'il doit dire
et ce qu'il doit dire c'est ce qu'il
pense vraiment
c'est ce qu'il ressent vraiment
tant pis si ça blesse tant pis si ça
déçoit c'est la vérité
la ligne conductrice de Meursault c'est
l'imperméabilité aux conventions
leur souhait est étranger au convention
et notamment à cette convention qui veut
que dans certaines situations on dit pas
ce que l'on pense
Meursault c'est celui qui est incapable
de jouer le jeu
de jouer le jeu c'est à dire me dire
quelque chose qu'il ne pense pas
il ne dit sans doute pas tout ce qu'il
pense mais il pense tout ce qu'il dit
et ça ça pose problème
pourquoi ça pose problème
ça pose problème parce que la société
estime qu'il y a des choses qu'on ne
peut pas dire
c'est qui la société
ben la société c'est tout le monde c'est
vous c'est moi c'est toute personne avec
qui on entretient une interaction
sociale
et entretenir une interaction sociale ça
suppose que dans certaines circonstances
il soit nécessaire d'en rabattre sur sa
sincérité
qu'il soit nécessaire de faire semblant
pour ne pas créer de malaise
pour ne pas gâcher le moment
pour ne pas passer pour un
pas pour
Meursault c'est celui qui refuse de
passer pour autre chose que ce qu'il
n'est
et quand je dis qu'il refuse en réalité
c'est presque un abus de langage
il refuse pas il est comme ça
dans le verbe refuser il y a l'idée
d'une intentionnalité
il y a l'idée d'un devoir
refusé c'est se dresser contre
en Meursault ne se dresse contre rien du
tout
il se contente juste d'être ce qu'il est
son refus des conventions ce n'est pas
un refus d'ordre moral ou politique
ce n'est pas un refus qui s'appuie sur
un discours
c'est un état physiologique
ce qui caractérise leur sceau c'est
l'indifférence physiologique au
conventions
comme me reçoit apprend que sa mère est
morte son premier réflexe c'est de se
dire qu'il va devoir faire deux heures
de bus pour aller à la maison de
retraite
préoccupation pratique
pas affective
quand il demande deux jours de congés à
son patron pour aller à l'enterrement il
ajoute ce n'est pas de ma faute
une phrase d'enfant
une phrase de quelqu'un qui ne comprend
pas que dans une situation pareille
personne ne lui en voudra
que la famille passe avant le travail
et qu'il y a même une désignation pour
ça
un cas de force majeure
Meursault est étranger au désignation
quand Marie le voit vêtu de noir elle
lui demande s'il est en deuil
et lui répond oui maman est morte
pas ma mère
maman
un mot d'enfant
Meursault est un enfant
c'est un enfant au sens où il n'a pas
intériorisé les conventions sociales
au sens où son rapport à l'existence est
placé sous le signe de l'immédiateté
et convention sont un intermédiaire
entre nous et le monde
elles sont le vêtement de nos
comportements
on recouvre notre corps de vêtements
pour recouvrir les organes de notre
animalité
et ses vêtements instaure une distance
entre chacun de nous qu'on appelle le
respect
étymologiquement respecter c'est
regarder en arrière
pour qu'il y ait respect il faut qu'il y
ait mis à distance
par exemple le vouvoiement c'est à la
fois une marque de distance et une
marque de respect
donc de la même façon qu'on habille
notre corps au nom du respect on habille
nos comportements au nom de ce même
respect
Meursault c'est celui qui n'abille pas
son comportement
c'est celui qui considère qu'habiller
c'est déjà travestir
c'est déjà déguisé
et déguisé c'est falsifié
c'est en cela que morceaux et l'homme de
l'immédiateté
et cet immédiateté on la retrouve non
seulement dans son comportement mais
aussi dans son intériorité mentale
dans son psychisme
l'étranger est un roman écrit à la
première personne
point de vue interne
donc on est censé être immergé dans la
conscience de Meursault
dans les moindres replis de sa pensée
et pourtant ces pensées on ne les
connaît pas
comme si il n'en n'avait pas
alors en réalité c'est pas tout à fait
vrai parce qu'à certaines occasions
Meursault a dépensé
par exemple quand il se rend compte que
Marie a été blessée par sa non
déclaration d'amour
ou quand ils se sont jugés par son
avocat
quand il dit il m'a regardé d'une façon
bizarre comme si je lui inspirais un peu
de dégoût
donc il y a des pensées chez Meursault
mais ces pensées sont ponctuelles
elles sont le prolongement de ses
impressions
et elles ne vont guère plus loin que nos
deux phrases
Meursault n'est pas un spéculatif
c'est un pragmatique
et sa pensée se limite à la formulation
de ces impressions
une pensée par bride par touche
l'esprit de Meursault c'est une toile
impressionniste
autrement dit Meursault n'est pas un
introverti qui parle peu mais qui pense
beaucoup
c'est un pragmatique qui dit ce qu'il
pense mais qui ne pense pas grand chose
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
permet de prolonger ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure à savoir que Meursault et
l'homme de l'immédiateté
autrement dit de la même façon que ces
paroles ne vont jamais plus loin que ces
pensées
ces pensées ne vont jamais plus loin que
ces impressions
en résumé Meursault est un homme aligné
son comportement est aligné avec ses
pensées autant que ses pensées sont
alignées avec ces impressions
et ça c'est pas rien
parce que ça veut dire qu'à bien y
réfléchir ces Meursault le plus normal
le plus normal au sens où une s’oblige
pas à des contorsions entre ce qu'ils
pensent et ce qu'il dit
il ne s'oblige pas à penser au-delà de
ce qu'il perçoit c'est à dire ajouter
des intermédiaires entre lui et le monde
des intermédiaires artificiels
superficiel
donc mensonger
et c'est ça qui fait de lui un étranger
Meursault était étranger à la corruption
qui fait loi dans la société
en société il est bien vu d'apparaître
comme un esprit sophistiqué
comme quelqu'un qui réfléchit plutôt qui
résonne
mais si raisonnée ces pensées toujours
au delà de ce qui est si raisonné c'est
s'éloigner d'autant de la réalité qu'à
l'arrivée on est sorti de la réalité
alors Meursault et l'homme de l'anti
raisonnement
si ces pensées semblent pauvres c'est
parce que sa conscience n'est pas
encombrée
elle n'est pas surchargée d'artifice
dont la finalité est de se détourner de
la réalité
le raisonnement nous aide à nier la
réalité
agnez les évidences
au point que pour certains
l'intelligence ce serait précisément la
capacité à nier les évidences
mais ça pour Meursault c'est le summum
du renversement des valeurs
faire passer la négation de la réalité
pour de la lucidité
faire passer l'illusion pour la vérité
raisonner ça vient de ratio en latin qui
signifie calcul
Meursault et l'homme de l'antical
réfléchir ça veut dire se courber
se plier en revenant sur soi
comme quand on dit que la lumière se
réfléchit
et le résultat de la réflexion c'est le
reflet
c'est le dédoublement
quand on réfléchit on se dédouble
on se divise
c'est la dissociation interne
et la société fait de nous des êtres
dissociés
dissocier entre ce que nous sommes et ce
que nous devons être
dissociés entre l'être et le paraître
nous sommes dissociés parce que nous
sommes constamment dans la projection
mentale de nous-mêmes
à nous demander comment nous devons nous
comporter qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire ou
ne pas dire
qu'est-ce qui se fait et qu'est-ce qui
ne se fait pas
et cette dissociation est une torture
quotidienne
en plus d'être une trahison quotidienne
de ce que nous sommes
Meursault n'est pas dissocié
il est entier
et le propre des individus entiers c'est
d'être regardé par les individus
dissociés comme des individus anormaux
parce que le système de convention qui
repose sur la dissociation fait que nous
avons intériorisé cette dissociation
comme normal
nous faisons oublier au passage que
normal ça veut dire conforme à la norme
nous avons fini par croire que normal
voulait dire naturel
mais c'est justement le contraire
le normal c'est le normé
et le normer c'est l'artificiel
donc dès lors qu'on a intégré comme
normal la dissociation l'homme entier
qui est Meursault ne peut passer que
pour un homme anormal
et si Meursault est un étranger c'est
dans la mesure où parce qu'il reste
entier il ne peut être que séparé du
monde des conventions
il ne peut être exclu
Meursault c'est le bouc émissaire
Meursault a conscience de ne pas être
tout à fait comme tout le monde
il en a conscience parce qu'il voit bien
que les gens le jugent
la thématique du jugement est
omniprésente dans l'étranger
le jugement dont on parle c'est le
jugement comme déconsidérations le
jugement comme mépris
ils se sont jugés par le directeur de la
maison de retraite comme s'il lui a été
reproché de ne pas être un bon fils
ils se sont jugés par son avocat quand
celui-ci lui demande s'il a été triste
le jour du décès de sa mère
et que Meursault lui répond la vérité à
savoir que non
Meursault n'admet pas d'être jugé pour
avoir dit la vérité
il considère qu'il ne devrait pas
culpabiliser pour avoir dit la vérité
et quand l'avocat lui dit qu'il ne peut
pas dire ça au tribunal qu'il va devoir
feindre la tristesse
ne se répond à nouveau non
non parce que c'est pas vrai
et que je ne vois pas pourquoi je
devrais mentir
c'est ça le crime de Meursault
son véritable crime
ce n'est pas d'avoir tué un homme on va
en parler
c'est de ne pas voir pourquoi il devrait
mentir
c'est de ne pas comprendre pourquoi il
devrait faire semblant
c'est de ne pas jouer le jeu social de
l'apparence
Meursault vit comme s'ils ne savait pas
que la vie en société c'est une vie en
représentation
on n'est pas on apparaît
on joue son rôle
au sens où Sartre disait que nous avions
tous besoin de jouer un rôle pour nous
conférer une identité
pour Meursault il n'y a pas de relater
et le comble c'est que ce soit quelqu'un
qui se moque des conventions qui sont
obligés de le rappeler
pourquoi c'est un comble
parce qu'au sommet de tous les principes
sur lesquels repose la société il y a la
vérité
l'éducation est basée là-dessus
on apprend à l'enfant à ne pas mentir à
ne pas tricher
à ne pas jouer la comédie
les escrocs sont envoyés en prison les
imposteurs sont livrés à la réprobation
sociale et voilà que tout à coup on
s'offusque quand enfin quelqu'un décide
de dire la vérité
oui ma mère est morte
et je n'étais pas triste
et alors
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
vous allez me jeter en prison
vous allez me condamner parce que je
n'ai pas pleuré à l'enterrement de ma
mère
vous allez me condamner parce que je
refuse de faire semblant
et bien oui
c'est exactement ce qu'il va se passer
Meursault va être condamné à mort
la société va exécuter un homme parce
qu'il a pris au mot les soi-disant
principes qui font de la vie en société
elle va exécuter un homme parce qu'il a
dit la vérité
Camus a écrit dans notre société tout
homme qui ne pleure pas à l'enterrement
de sa mère risque d'être condamné à mort
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que celui qui ne joue pas
le jeu social le jeu de la simulation
affective mais en péril les conditions
de la vie en société
parce que celui qui ne pleure pas à
l'enterrement de sa mère sera fatalement
jugé comme inhumain
comme un monstre
et un monstre c'est un danger pour la
société
la société juge parce que la société se
protège
elle se protège contre les individus
quel juge malfaisant
sauf quand vous lance se protéger elle
transforme la vie en comédie sociale
on fait des démonstrations d'indignation
on parle à la place des gens
on brandit le bâton du savoir-vivre
lors de son procès Meursault est
interpellé par le fait que son avocat
par la sa place
allant même jusqu'à utiliser le pronom
je
Meursault ne comprend pas
il demande aux policiers qui est assis à
côté de lui pourquoi il fait ça
le policier lui dira tous les avocats
font ça
traduction c'est normal
c'est normal de parler à la place des
autres
c'est normal de ne pas s'intéresser à
l'intéresser
c'est normal de juger quelqu'un dont on
ne sait rien à partir de l'image qu'on
s'est construite de lui
c'est normal
dans l'étranger le tribunal représente
l'archétype du cirque social
les événements serait toriques
l'affichage émotionnel l'extrapolation
et l'enfermement dans des cases
l'accusé et dans un box
une boîte
Meursault Les finalement pas coupable du
meurtre qu'il a commis
il est coupable d'inhumanité
ça peut aller très vite de passer pour
une humain
et ce que nous dit Camus c'est que pour
être jugé humain il n'y a pas besoin de
l'être
il suffit d'en avoir l'air
de le paraître
encore et toujours le paraître
vous savez quand un tueur en série se
fait arrêter et que les médias en font
le portrait on entend souvent dire ça
avait l'air de quelqu'un de tout à fait
normal
un homme sans histoire comme si on
pouvait être sans histoire
un homme que personne n'aurait soupçonné
parce qu'on juge aux apparences
c'est comme ça
donc évidemment le tueur en série ne
s'affiche pas comme tueur en série
il se fait discret
il se fond dans la masse
il cherche à passer pour monsieur tout
le monde
il va au travail il paye ses impôts
il salue ses voisins quand il les croise
parce que le paraître social et sa
meilleure protection
d'ailleurs tous les grands malfrats ont
ce qu'on appelle une couverture
un faux non un faux métier le plus banal
possible
une voiture passe partout
ce qui ne veulent pas attirer
l'attention sur eux
c'est la scène d'American gangster dans
laquelle Frank Lucas est vu au Madison
Square Garden avec un manteau de
fourrure sur le dos un cadeau de sa
femme
et à cause de ce manteau il est repéré
par un policier qui enquête sur lui
et qui se dit qui est ce type qui porte
un manteau comme celui là
ça doit être quelqu'un d'important
parce que c'est le genre de manteau que
porte les gens importants
c'est le genre de manteau qui envoie un
message socialement
et quand Franck Lucas comprend qu'il a
attiré les soupçons à cause de ce
manteau cadeau de sa femme ou pas il le
jette au feu
et il s'en veut
il s'en veut parce qu'il savait que
porter ce manteau était une erreur
c'était paraître ce qu'il était
un gangster
dans le cas de Meaux c'est l'inverse
Meursault ne cherche pas à soigner les
apparences
il est prêt aucune importance
et que c'est à cause de ça qu'il a été
condamné
et vous qui m'écoutez même si vous vous
dites que vous vous ne jugez pas sur les
apparences c'est pas vrai
on juge tous sur les apparences
même si ensuite on se ravise même si
ensuite on modifie notre jugement
mais en première intention on juge sur
le paraître
et on cesse de juger sur le paraître
quand on commence à découvrir l'être
c'est exactement ce qui se produit quand
la fiancée de Meursault Marie est
interroger lors du procès
rappelons que Marie aime Meursault
et lorsque le procureur lui demande de
décrire le comportement de Meursault au
lendemain du décès de sa mère là aussi
elle lui raconte la vérité
qu'ils sont allés à la plage
qu'ils sont allés au cinéma
qu'ils ont passé la nuit ensemble
bref elle a décrit comme un homme
charmant
elle pensait sans doute que son
témoignage
allait casser l'image que le procureur
avez-vous dû construire de Meursault
celle d'un homme insensible
et ben c'était raté
vous voyez a-t-il procureur
un homme dont la mère vient de mourir et
qui s'amuse
qui badine avec sa maîtresse qui va rire
devant des films comiques
ai-je besoin d'en rajouter
il n'avait pas besoin d'en rajouter
parce qu'il savait que tout le monde
dans la salle d'audience allez en
conclure
Meursault n'a pas de cœur
car s'il avait un cœur
il aurait été triste
il n'aurait pas eu le cœur à s'amuser
c'était ça son crime
s'amuser
s'amuser quand la société attendait de
lui qu'il pleure
depuis tout à l'heure je vous parle d'un
homme meurto qui a commis un meurtre et
qui est jugé pour ce meurtre
la réalité c'est que Meursault n'est pas
jugé pour son meurtre mais pour sa
personne
le meurtre n'est quasiment jamais évoqué
lors du procès
ce qui est évoqué c'est la personnalité
de Meursault
son insensibilité son détachement
mais le meurtre qu'il a commis et bien
réel
et il faut qu'on en parle
donc de quoi s'agit-il
Meursault se lit d'amitié avec l'un de
ses voisins d'immeubles Raymond
et Raymond a un problème
il est suivi par un homme qui
visiblement veut lui rectifier le
portrait
Raymond sait très bien qui est cet homme
c'est le frère de sa maîtresse une
Algérienne qu'il maltraite et qui a fini
par le quitter
on apprendra plus tard que Raymond était
son souteneur
un jour Raymond est Meursault se promène
sur une plage
et là il tombe sur deux hommes
le frère de la maîtresse et un ami à lui
une bagarre se déclenche
mais le frère un couteau
et il blesse Raymond au bras
un peu plus tard me ressort retourne sur
la plage et il retombe sur le frère
et là au lieu de simplement passer son
chemin
il s'approche de lui
il sort son revolver de sa poche
et tire
l'homme est abattu
Meursault laisse passer quelques
secondes
et tire à nouveau
4 balles
quatre balles sur ce corps inerte
cette scène que je viens de vous résumer
brièvement habituellement nommé la scène
du meurtre de l'arabe se situe au milieu
du roman
une manière de dire qu'il y a un avant
et un après
effectivement ce meurtre c'est
l'événement qui va faire basculer le
destin de Meursault
on ignore pourquoi Meursault a tiré sur
cet homme
alors oui il y avait une bagarre peu de
temps avant l'homme n'avait pas l'air
animait par les meilleurs intentions
mais là ces morceaux qui est allé vers
lui
en le voyant s'approcher l'arabe a sorti
son couteau
comme pour lui signifier de ne pas
s'approcher davantage
mais ces Meursault qui est allé au
devant lui
ce n'était donc pas un cas de légitime
défense
est-ce que ça aurait pu être de la
vengeance
venger Raymond pour le coup de couteau
qui l'a reçu
c'est peu probable
d'abord parce que l'amitié entre
Meursault et Raymond était très relative
il ne se connaissait que depuis peu et
puis surtout une plaie dans le bras ça
lui suffit pas un meurtre
en tout cas pas pour Meursault
d'ailleurs ces Meursault qui a dit que
ce genre de problème devait se régler à
la loyal
un contre un et pas d'armes
Raymond voulait utiliser le revolver ces
Meursault qu'il en a dissuadé
et pourtant il l'a tué
lorsqu'il sera interrogé me ressent
finira par dire que la véritable raison
tu meurtre de l'arabe
c'était le soleil
une réponse absurde
une réponse absurde et qui justement
parce qu'elle est absurde va nous
éclairer sur le sens de cet acte et
au-delà sur le sens de l'étranger
tout au long du roman Meursault semble
souffrir d'une hypersensibilité
sensorielle
il est sensible à la lumière il en est
question à maintes reprises dans le
livre
il est sensible à la chaleur
au bruit aux odeurs
autrement dit autant c'est un personnage
qui a l'air insensible émotionnellement
autant c'est un personnage extrêmement
sensible corporellement
il aime le contact de l'eau quand il se
baigne il aime le contact de la peau de
Marie quand il la caresse
il aime le café que lui sert le
concierge
c'est ce qu'on appelle un hédoniste
et d'ailleurs lorsqu'il est en prison il
explique que le plus dur pour lui ce
n'est pas l'isolement
le plus dur c'est la privation de femmes
et de cigarettes
en clair c'est le manque physique
au point qu'il en arrive à la conclusion
que ça doit être ça la privation de
liberté
l'absence de plaisir physique
donc Meursault a un rapport corporel à
la vie
et ça c'est très révélateur
c'est très révélateur parce que ça
rejoint ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure à
savoir que Meursault est dans
l'immédiateté
Meursault ne pense pas il éprouve
dans une interview qu'il a donné en 1955
Camus dit de lui-même qu'avant d'être un
homme qui pense il est d'abord un homme
qui éprouve
et que sa pensée ce n'est finalement que
la mise en forme de son vécu sensoriel
ça s'applique parfaitement à Meursault
Meursault est un homme qui éprouve
et qui pour ainsi dire se confond avec
ses sensations
il y a un passage extrêmement
intéressant à la fin du roman c'est
qu'en morceaux explique que pour passer
le temps en prison il s'amuse à se
souvenir de chaque détail de son
ancienne chambre
et qu'au début ça ne prenait que
quelques minutes mais qu'au bout d'un
moment ça pouvait durer des heures
meurt soda il suffit de vivre une seule
journée pour avoir des souvenirs pendant
70 ans
mais si vous faites l'expérience vous
allez voir que c'est très difficile
comme exercice
faites le test partez d'un angle de
votre chambre ou de votre salon et
passons en revue tout ce que vous voyez
vous allez voir que vous n'allez pas
tenir des heures
pas par impatience mais juste par manque
de souvenirs
on ne se souvient pas de chaque détail
de sa maison
parce qu'on n'y est pas attentif
c'est d'ailleurs le propre de tous les
environnements familiers
on y fait pas attention
donc pour que Meursault soit capable de
se souvenir de chaque détail de son
ancienne chambre il faut nécessairement
que ce soit quelqu'un d'attentif
de sensoriellement attentif
mais donc pas détaché du monde au
contraire
ce qui définit morceau c'est la présence
au monde
l'ultra présente
et s'il semble détaché c'est au sens où
il est détaché de ceux qui en sont
détachés
Meursault n'est pas détaché du monde
il est détaché du monde des humains
du monde social
précisément parce que le monde social et
la négation du monde
le monde conventionnel et la négation du
monde réel
et c'est ce détachement au monde
conventionnel qui fait de Meursault un
étranger
donc on aurait tort de dire que
Meursault est étranger au monde
il était étranger à ce que les êtres
humains veulent faire du monde
et qu'est-ce que les êtres humains
veulent faire du monde
ils veulent faire du monde quelque chose
qui a du sens
meurto était étranger à tous les
systèmes qui prétendent donner du sens
pour Meursault le monde n'a pas de sens
la vie n'a pas de sens
elle est absurde
est-ce que cherche à faire les hommes
ces données du sens à quelque chose qui
n'en a pas
c'est le rôle des conventions
c'est le rôle du contrat social
le contrat social nous dit tu dois
respecter ton prochain
car ton prochain est ton compagnon
d'existence
ok très bien mais dans ce cas là vous me
demandez de faire comme si mon existence
avec l'importance
comme si son existence avec l'importance
encore une fois vous me demandez de
faire semblant
c'est ça la réponse de Meursault au
contrat social
vous me demandez de croire que les
choses ont du sens
pire de faire semblant de le croire
mais c'est vous qui faites semblant
vous faites semblant de croire que votre
vie a un sens
et c'est pour ça que vous te détend à ce
que les autres y croient aussi
pour qu'il continue à respecter vos
conventions
vous croyez que vos conventions vont
vous faire oublier que vous savez que
votre vie est absurde
c'est ça le rôle de vos tribunaux
de vos prisons
de vos maisons de retraite
comprennent la vie au sérieux
qu'on fasse semblant de croire que tout
ça ça a une importance
viens moi je ne veux pas faire semblant
et je veux dire tout ça n'a aucune
importance
la vie n'a aucune importance
parce qu'elle n'a pas de sens
Meursault est dans l'immédiateté avec la
vie
et c'est pour ça qu'il refuse de
disserter sur le sens de la vie
ce qui discerne sur le sens de la vie
sont ceux qui veulent oublier que la vie
n'a pas de sens
et pour l'oublier il remplisse le vide
de considération encore plus vide
pour Meursault les discours sur le sens
de l'existence c'est encore plus absurde
que l'existence elle-même
parce que ces discours prétendent avoir
quelque chose de pertinent à dire sur
quelque chose qui part définition ne
peut que nous échapper
donc pourquoi faire des discours
c'est la phrase de Meursault devant le
juge d'instruction quand on lui dit que
les gens le décrivent comme quelqu'un de
renfermé et qu'il répond je n'ai jamais
grand chose à dire
alors je me tais
ce à quoi le juge d'instruction répond
c'est la meilleure des raisons
tout le monde a son opinion sur le sens
de la vie
même ceux qui pensent que la vie n'a pas
de sens
et qui ont d'ailleurs souvent un
discours très argumenté sur le non sens
de la vie
mais ce faisant il continue d'accorder
de l'importance au discours
il continue d'incarner sans quoi il
prétendent ne pas croire
à savoir que les choses ont du sens
quand la vie n'a pas de sens il n'y a
rien à dire
rien à démontrer
pas même qu'elle n'a pas de sens
il suffit d'en être conscient
il suffit de ne pas faire semblant
d'accepter cette vérité
les gens n'aiment pas le silence
parce qu'il n'aime pas le vide
le vide et source d'angoisse
il nous rappelle que tout ça n'a aucun
sens
c'est dangereux les silences
dans le mythe de Sisyphe Camus écrit
l'absurde naît de cette confrontation
entre l'appel humain et le silence des
raisonnable du monde
l'appel humain c'est le besoin de sens
le silence du monde c'est l'absence de
réponse
un silence des raisonnable parce que
l'absence de sens peut rendre fou
on peut être raisonnable qu'à partir du
moment où notre vie est structuré par du
sens
c'est la vie n'a plus de sens la société
n'a plus de sens
les lois n'ont plus de sens
ma présence à ce tribunal n'a plus de
sens
aux yeux de Meursault la société est
régie par le déni
elle est régie par l'illusion
illusion au sens de ce qui recouvre la
réalité pour la rendre supportable
car il y a plus absurde que l'existence
il y a le recouvrement de l'absurde
la société est une structure de
camouflage
Meursault c'est celui qui a compris que
la vie n'avait pas de sens et qu'il
accepte
et c'est cet acceptation qui le rend
étranger au monde de l'illusion du sens
à la société des hommes qui vivent comme
si leur vie avait du sens
qui font semblant
qui masque la réalité de l'absurde par
les ombres du sens
Meursault c'est le prisonnier de la
caverne qui est sorti de la caverne
qui a vu le soleil
qui a vu l'organe cosmique de la vérité
et qui dorénavant connaît la vérité
à savoir que la vie est absurde
et semblable aux prisonniers de la
caverne de Platon
s'il redescend dans la caverne pour dire
aux autres prisonniers que le monde est
absurde
il risque la mort
car les gens le prendront pour un fou
c'est ce qui va lui arriver
et c'est là qu'on en revient au soleil
ce soleil dont meurtsau dira qu'il est
la cause de son crime
pourtant le soleil n'a pas tenu le
revolver
le soleil n'a rien ordonné à Meursault
non
mais il a exercé sur lui une pression
une pression physique
et l'hypersensibilité sensorielle de
Meursault c'est la porte par laquelle le
soleil s'est introduit pour le pousser à
commettre son crime
si le soleil est bien l'organe cosmique
de la vérité et que la vérité du monde
c'est l'absurde alors le soleil s'est
emparé de Meursault pour se manifester
au monde
Meursault c'est le Christ du soleil
son crime c'est la vérité
l'absurde peut se manifester sous de
multiples formes
mais l'une de ces formes privilégiées
c'est la mort
plus particulièrement la Morgane
innocent
quoi de plus absurde que la mort
d'animaux sont
la mort d'un enfant par exemple à
quelque chose d'effroyable
et c'était froid et renforcé par le fait
que même si toute vie aboutit à la mort
dans la logique de la vie elle-même un
enfant ne devrait pas mourir
ce n'est pas dans l'ordre des choses
une personne âgée qui meurt même si
c'est triste ça reste dans l'ordre des
choses
ça reste dans l'ordre du sens
donc pour se manifester au monde
l'absurde par l'intermédiaire de
Meursault devait se matérialiser dans
une mort absurde
et si je dis que c'est l'absurde
lui-même qui s'empare de Meursault pour
se manifester c'est parce que cette idée
d'appropriation cette idée que le soleil
a pris possession de Meursault elle est
présente dans le texte
la phrase la plus explicite étant en
même temps la plus déterminante dans le
meurtre
la gâchette à céder
pas j'ai tiré
la gâchette a cédé
comme pour dire je n'y suis pour rien
ce n'est pas moi
c'est le soleil
la conscience de la mort et sans doute
le mode de manifestation de l'absurde le
plus abouti
on va mourir et on le sait
mais pourquoi le savoir
quel intérêt de le savoir
si ce n'est de nous plonger dans une
angoisse telle qu'on soit obligé de
créer des conventions pour l'oublier
comme si la civilisation était la
finalité de notre mortalité
l'absurde naît du conflit entre deux
impossibilités
comprendre le sens de l'existence
et faire taire en nous la voix qui
s'interroge
les conventions et au-delà des
conventions la civilisation
ont pour fonction de faire taire la voix
qui s'interroge
la voix qui a conscience que tout ça est
absurde
alors on élève des tours
on est riche des temples
on crée des lois
et on y investit du sens
on se crée des situations à gérer des
problèmes à résoudre
et ça nous occupe
le travail et le meilleur rempart à la
conscience de l'absurde
le travail
occupe l'esprit
il rend la conscience silencieuse
et quand la mort se présente à nous pour
nous rappeler de temps en temps que la
vie est absurde
il faut vite s'en emparer pour la mettre
dans un système de sens
les obsèques la succession
les registres
la mort devient une partie de la vie
elle devient un dossier que l'on peut
classer
il faut rapatrier la mort dans le champ
du sens pour qu'elle cesse d'être une
source d'angoisse
il faut en faire une affaire
administrative
une affaire sociale
raison pour laquelle la seule mort qui
ne soit pas absurde du point de vue de
la société c'est la mort d'un condamné
une mort dont on pourra alors se dire
qu'elle a du sens
parce qu'elle est juste
quand Meursault est condamné à mort sa
mort est un moyen de donner du sens au
monde
on tue les criminels
on tue les tueurs
donc on neutralise l'absurde
tuer un condamné c'est prendre l'absurde
à revers
c'est tué au nom de la prohibition du
meurtre
prohibition du meurtre qui donne du sens
à la vie
la vie doit forcément avoir de la valeur
pour qu'il soit interdit de la supprimer
la seule mort dont on veut croire
qu'elle a du sens c'est la mort qu'on
inscrit dans la loi
une mort acceptable parce qu'elle est
censée exclurger le crime
donc expurger l'absurde
la ritualisation de la condamnation à
mort est un exorcisme contre l'absurde
c'est ce que dit Meursault avec un peu
de sarcasme
le président m'a dit que j'aurai la tête
tranchée sur une place publique au nom
du peuple français
ou comment donner l'illusion du sens à
quelque chose qui n'en a pas
Meursault n'a pas seulement tu es un
homme
il lui attire et dessus alors qu'il
était déjà mort
4 fois
un geste encore plus absurde que le
meurtre en lui-même
quand le juge d'instruction demande à un
morceau pourquoi il a tiré quatre balles
dans un corps inerte
Meursault n'a pas répondu
il s'est tue
le silence déraisonnable du monde
Meursault ne pouvait pas répondre
il l'ignorait
on ne peut comprendre le sens de ce
meurtre qu'en comprenant comme un saut a
été manipulé par l'absurde lui-même
pour lui faire commettre ce dont la
société a le plus peur
à savoir la monstruosité silencieuse
le geste de Meursault n'était pas
absurde
il était le geste de l'absurde
face à son silence le juge d'instruction
devient fou
pourquoi mais pourquoi
pourquoi ces quatre coups
il veut comprendre
il a besoin de comprendre
son équilibre en dépend
sa vie en dépend
il le dit même
voulez-vous que ma vie n'est pas de sens
drôle de phrase pour un juge
d'instruction
voulez-vous que ma vie n'est pas de sens
parce que oui notre vie ne repose que
sur notre capacité à donner du sens aux
choses
enlever du sens c'est enlever une raison
de continuer à vivre
et c'est là qu'intervient la question de
Dieu
le juge d'instruction demande à
Meursault s'il croit en Dieu
Meursault répond que non
il est atteint
e ce qui fait bondir le jeu
d'instruction
et on peut le comprendre
il passe ses journées à interroger des
criminels
donc à interroger des gens qui se sont
illustrés par un geste de négation du
sens de la vie
Dieu est son dernier rempart
son dernier rempart face à l'absurde
tous les criminels qui passent dans son
bureau il veut lire sur leur visage le
remord la culpabilité
la culpabilité étant un moyen a
posteriori de sauvegarder le sens
oui j'ai commis l'absurde
mais je le regrette
le regret c'est quand on demande pardon
au sens
Meursault n'a aucun remords
il ne regrette pas son geste
il est juste ennuyé par les
répercussions de son acte
le procès la prison tout ça
Meursault ne croit pas en Dieu et c'est
même le seul sujet qui arrive à le
mettre en colère
parce que pour lui Dieu est le plus
grand des mensonges collectifs
celui qui prétend détenir le sens ultime
vous ne comprenez pas le sens de
l'existence
n'ayez crainte la réponse est en Dieu
vous avez des regrets
demandez pardon à Dieu
on a tué vos enfants
Dieu est à vos côtés
lorsqu'il est en prison en attente de
son exécution il refuse les visites de
l'aumônier
et finalement au bout de la quatrième
fois il accepte d'échanger quelques mots
avec lui
l'aumônier joue son rôle de Monnier il
tente de le convaincre une dernière fois
d'ouvrir son cœur à Dieu
et là me ressources emporte
il lève la voix il insulte
et lui dit que croire en Dieu c'est être
déjà mort
parce que c'est nier le fait que
l'existence se vit au présent
pour Meursault la vie c'est d'ici est
maintenant
ce n'est que ici et maintenant
il sait qu'il va mourir
mais il sait aussi que tout le monde va
mourir
et la différence entre lui et les autres
c'est que lui en a conscience
et qu'il ne cherche pas à se voiler la
face derrière des illusions comme Dieu
oui je vais mourir
mais je le sais et je l'accepte
je n'ai pas peur
parce que j'aurais vécu
c'est la seule chose qui compte
avoir vécu
avoir vécu et se dire que si je devais
avoir une deuxième vie
je voudrais la passer à me souvenir de
celle-ci
il y a du Nietzsche chez Camus
l'éternel retour
vivre comme si nous pouvions souhaiter
que notre vie se répète indéfiniment
au départ meurto est-ce qu'on pourra
appeler un absurde négatif
un absurde passif
un nihiliste
il n'a pas d'ambition
c'est un désillusionné
comme il le dira quand j'étais étudiant
j'avais beaucoup d'ambition mais quand
j'ai dû abandonner mes études j'ai très
vite compris que tout cela est sans
importance réelle
sans importance c'est ça qui définit le
rapport à l'existence du premier morceau
un morceau qui dit de lui-même qu'il
n'est pas malheureux que sa vie ne lui
déplaît pas
que les choses n'ont pas de valeur pas
de signification
la grammaire du premier Meursault est
négative
la grammaire du deuxième morceau le
morceau d'après la colère contre
l'aumônier est positive
Meursault devient heureux positivement
heureux après avoir vaincu Dieu
après avoir vaincu
l'illusion suprême
qui nous maintient dans le déni
la cause des causes n'existe pas
elle nous échappe
bien qu'elle s'échappe
on n'a pas besoin de cause
quand on est dans la présence
je cite
c'était comme si j'avais attendu pendant
tout le temps 7 minutes et cette petite
eau bouge serait justifiée rien rien
n'avait d'importance et je savais bien
pourquoi lui aussi savait pourquoi du
fond de mon avenir pendant toute cette
vie absurde que j'avais menée un souffle
obscur remonté vers moi à travers des
années qui n'étaient pas encore venu et
ce souffle légalisé sur mon passage tout
ce qu'on me proposait alors dans les
années pas plus réelles que je vivais
comme un portait la mort des autres
l'amour d'une mère comme importait son
Dieu les vies qu'on choisit les destins
qu'on élits puisqu’un seul destin devait
mellir moi-même et avec moi des
milliards de privilégiés qui comme lui
se disait mes frères comprenait-il
comprenait-il donc tout le monde était
privilégié il n'y avait que des
privilégiés les autres aussi ont les
condamnerait un jour lui aussi on le
condamnerait qu'importer si accusé de
meurtre il était exécuté pour en avoir
pas pleuré à l'enterrement de sa mère le
chien de Salamano valait autant que sa
femme la petite femme automatique était
aussi coupable que la Parisienne que
maçon avait épousé ou que Marie qui
avait envie que je l'épouse qu'importer
que Raymond fut mon copain autant que
céleste qui valait mieux que lui
qu'importe comment Harry donna
aujourd'hui sa bouche à un nouveau
meurto comprenait-il donc ce condamné et
que du fond de mon avenir j'ai tout fait
en criant tout ceci mais déjà on
m'arrachait l'aumônier des mains et les
gardiens me menaçaient lui cependant les
a calmés et m'a regardé un moment en
silence il avait les yeux plein de
larmes il s'est détourné et il a disparu
lui parti j'ai retrouvé le calme j'étais
épuisé et je me suis jeté sur ma
couchette je crois que j'ai dormi parce
que je me suis réveillé avec des étoiles
sur le visage des bruits de campagne
monté jusqu'à moi des odeurs de nuit de
terre et de sel rafraîchissait mes
tempes la merveilleuse paix de cet été
endormie entrée en moi comme une marée à
ce moment et à la limite de la nuit des
sirènes ont hurlé elles annonçaient des
départs pour un monde qui maintenant
mettait à jamais indifférent pour la
première fois depuis longtemps j'ai
pensé à maman il m'a semblé que je
comprenais pourquoi à la fin d'une vie
elle avait pris un fiancé pourquoi elle
avait joué à recommencé là-bas aussi
autour de cet asile ou des vies seignées
le soir était comme une trêve
mélancolique si près de la mort maman
devait s'y sentir libérer et prête à
tout revivre personne personne avait le
droit de pleurer sur elle et moi aussi
je me suis senti prêt à tout revivre
comme si cette grande colère m'avait
purgé du mal vider d'espoir devant cette
nuit chargée de signer d'étoiles je
m'ouvrais pour la première fois à
l'attendre indifférence du monde de
l'éprouver si pareil à moi s'y fraternel
enfin j'ai senti que j'avais été heureux
et que je l'étais encore
Camus a écrit
Meursault et le seul Christ que nous
méritions
le Christ a été crucifié devant une
foule qui lui criait sa haine
Meursault sera guillotiné sur une place
publique avec l'espoir que la foule lui
criera sa haine
si la foule vous exécute sous des cris
de haine c'est que la société du faux de
l'illusion
vous aura identifié comme son ennemi
c'est que vous êtes porteur d'une vérité
que la société ne peut pas vous laisser
propager
elle vous tuera donc
et elle jettera sur vous la honte et le
déshonneur
Meursault accepte de mourir pour
incarner la plus profonde vérité de ce
monde à savoir que la vie est absurde
et c'est à partir du moment où il
accepte son sort où il l'accepte du plus
profond de son être
qu'il se réconcilie avec la vie
car après tout la vie est pour rien
le suicide n'est pas une solution à
l'absurde
la solution à l'absurde c'est la révolte
la révolte c'est le choix d'une
troisième voie entre l'angoisse et le
mensonge
l'acceptation qui nous fait nous sentir
en vie
qui fait que chaque parcelle de notre
peau
vibre d'une intensité infinie
peut-être que le meurtre qu'a commimero
n'était qu'un suicide différé
tu es pour être tué
me reçois tu allais au devant de la
réprobation
il est allé au devant de la fatalité
parce que c'est le seul moyen de
conjurer l'absurde
de le pousser à son extrémité pour
finalement
l'évacuer dans un cri de colère contre
Dieu
l'absurde et comme le mal
il ne se combat pas
il s'embrasse
je vous remercie
[Musique]